welcome back to the joke World comedy
news update today's story Shane Gillis
is officially moving to Austin Texas
it's the new comedy Hub this
announcement was made during a live
taping of the real ass podcast in Austin
Texas that featured an insane lineup of
special guests including shangilis Ari
shaffir Mark Norman Tony Hinchcliffe and
Brian redband I want to make a special
announcement right now okay ladies and
gentlemen Shane Gillis is moving to
Austin Texas oh boy
that is not public knowledge yeah I hate
this down
but I guess I'll live here it seems like
it seems like you hate it I actually
yeah I know it's fine